Hey Youtubers it's Charlie surprise surprise,
there's Warcraft footage.
So equip your raid gear and meet me at Blackrock
foundry and let's break it down raise your
hand if you are at one point or are still
addicted to World of Warcraft note no judging
I feel you can call yourself a warcry fan
if you haven't been addicted to it at some
point to the detriment of the rest of your
life Rob Kaczynski who is playing all grim
here so that he actually lost one of his girlfriends
to warcraft Henry cavill missed the first
call that he got Superman like that he was
cast of Superman because he was in a raid
with his guild on the work time I certainly
have played a lot in the cost to memorable
range that's a very good question that when
it first came out to their there's so many
people at so many levels of society that have
played warcraft that I feel like we need our
own support group and the movie actually looks
pretty awesome it's in the vein of avatar
words like this immersive CG world I wouldn't
be surprised if they do some sort of VR tie
in with the movie whenever to release next
year most of the people that are making VR
headsets like Sony and valve are starting
to release and this Christmas shopping season
so usually like it takes a good six months
before you start seeing really good software
for stuff like that you see a console first
to see like one or two big release titles
and then several months later you start to
see the really cool stuff so hopefully by
the time the movie comes out they'll have
some interactive VR content that even though
this clip is supershort and is not a lot like
close up of the faces there a lot of familiar
actors here do you recognize from other places
Dominic Cooper is playing King Lane ran the
visit was a couple different versions but
most of his history is tied up in orcs versus
humans my initial interaction with the game
was with warcraft to we used to play in the
physics computer lab in high school because
they were all network Max you Doolan play
with a couple different people is also good
pull take raise your hand if you got caught
playing warcraft some instance of warcraft
were craft to work for F3 on the school computer
and had to stay after school but most of my
teachers were pretty cool I never got suspended
for playing warcraft on school computers they
would kick you out by the seat of your pants
like just to get that hot here then fosters
playing with the very famous person or warcraft
history I remember when the first warcraft
to expansion came out that was one of the
coolest cut scenes ever him opening the portal
Travis symbols playing Andrew and Lothar here
Ruth Negga you may remember from agent to
shield is playing lady Terry of Paula Patton
playing Garona bench sets nurse playing R
and then again the orcs you have Clancy Brown
who's playing Blackhand I'm always a fan of
Clancy Brown everything he shows up his like
the most amazing voice Rob Kaczynski's is
that is playing all grim Ryan Robbins who
is on arrow right now is actually playing
a character that we don't know yet some guessing
this kinda spoiler he Daniel Cudmore who plays
colossus in the classic Brian Singer X-Men
movies he's in it to his characters also secret
Toby Campbell's planked or tan here Callum
Rennie is playing more rows we we don't seem
in this teaser here but he's such a huge characters
gonna be really awesome seeing him just a
places in the timeline what they're doing
is as they are picking up with orcs versus
humans, where the lore is around those games
and then though build on that when they do
future films you can let me know though is
there a particular period of warcraft lore
the you want them to do a movie based on I
think a unit of this first movie successful
enough to totally spin out a big franchise
so they'll be able to hit like all the big
stuff in getting blizzard continues to write
new lore as they release new content so as
long as the movies are good will keep seeing
them within the big thing to do is I'm wondering
is if the gonna be releasing special content
when the movie comes out because they release
the latest patch last year so that they're
trying to time things so they can do stuff
for the videogame and stuff for the movie
in fact I think I'll actually do like a blizzard
giveaway with the trailer video that I post
on Friday like when the full trailer post
oriented and are is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video may be looking at
the mouth giveaway or something like that
it has been a little while the play the game
I'm still paying for my subscription but I
stop playing actively after the first patch
and Mists of Pandaria that was about the time
when I started making YouTube videos that
but that's a good like every minute of free
time I had but I still do login to get world
achievements every once in a while I think
I like about work practice that like even
if you go away for like six months or year
whatever like if you to go to school your
time to play you can always come back later
and you still get a lot of those seasonal
achievements but I don't really consider myself
an achievement or other you get upset if you
miss one there are many be sure to check the
schedule again for seasonal achievements coming
up in the and the holiday season make sure
you login at least once the you get them there
is big stuff happening tonight to working
to meet Jesse quick on the flash and this
new agents of shield episode I think were
supposed to learn who Lash is going to be
so white he is the best of the post you can
click here for my last flash trailer video
and you can click here for your potential
reveal about Rey's character in Star Wars
the force awakens there was a toy commercial
that may have given a few things away and
says that all the time and thank you so much
watching for watching, everybody let's high
five and I'll see you guys tonight!